j'accueille andré dussollier
il
on va le jouer honnêtement qu'est ce qui
vous perdre dans des endroits pareils
vous qui a tué c'est une grande première
ben oui on la sait je suis flatté bas
nous aussi on est très plat que c'est
plutôt rare en télévision non plutôt ici
et je passe pas mal de temps à
travailler et le pire de jouer au héros
me satisfait
vous avez dit d'ailleurs le besoin
galopant de notoriété pervertit tout
nous sommes désormais invitée dans les
émissions de télévision
non pas pour parler de notre métier mais
de notre vie ça attaque n'est pas vrai
j'ai eu dix on va parler un peu des deux
vous avez 55 en 30 ans de carrière j'ai
fait plus de 50 films avec lelouch
chabrol rennais sauter scola vous avez
fait trois hommes et un couffin que d'un
monument national
la suite va bientôt sortir 18 ans après
avec le même casting vous effet on
connaît la chanson
chef-d'oeuvre les enfants du marais qui
a séduit beaucoup de français 40
téléfilm 20 pièces de théâtre est ce
qu'on peut dire bravo du du pavot est dû
non j'ai encore plein de choses que j'ai
envie de faire mais je sais pas
l'appétit vient en mangeant donc il ya
des rôles il ya des que je n'ai pas
abordés des gens aussi que ce n'est pas
assez exploré
donc non ça s'arrête pas j'ai pas envie
que ça s'arrête
vous avez une actualité c'est comment on
fait avec les petites mains comme quand
on insulte un relevé de prix attention
attention dussollier faire ça c'est mon
bonnet attention bref voilà alors vous
avez une actualité chargée
d'abord faut dire à ceux qui ne savent
pas que vous êtes la voix off du carton
de l'année 7 million et demi de
spectateurs amélie poulain le narrateur
c'est andré dussollier vais pas été
payés au pourcentage c'est le problème
quoi un personne si tout le monde avait
su bien sûr ils m'ont auraient été
payées 100 tu as vu un cachet mais oui
mais c'est très content 1l faire cette
fois c'était tout à fait inattendu et
puis c'est un personnage qui qui compte
alors aprilia vidocq fait le rôle du
préfet de police un personnage très
dessinée très caricaturer corse et
redingote choses très étonnant
personnage très très étonnant ça qui
casse un peu votre image via is wrong
amusé c'est à dire de faire des
personnages très différents c'est un peu
le privilège de l'âge c'est pas ou de
l'addition ldd film donc que vous dont
vous avez parlé de talais revoilà et
puis à la chambre des officiers très
très beau film de françois dupeyron
d'après le roman de marc dugain avec
géraldine pailhas qui était notre invité
la semaine dernière ne fait pas l'amour
à 50 du tout de suite voilà ni à 4 eric
caravaca sabine azéma denis podalydès